all right we've tried to avoid saying
this all morning just because it's
pretty sad it's a sad day here at good
day las vegas
our friend my co-anchor alex backus is
leaving the program
oh well from everyone behind the scenes
to us here in front of the camera
alex will miss you a lot and i really
mean it
and i'm sure a lot of us really mean it
we're really going to miss you
absolutely it's been a real pleasure
getting to know you alex from the first
day you got here and you auditioned for
the job
to uh moving on with your future we know
we'll be seeing you
but also i think john we have some
pictures to share here's a look at some
of our favorite times together
have we have we lost alex alex are you
with us earth to
why does this happen every day alex john
will take anything
[Music]
that did not sound right okay never mind
so fault it
i still have not turned my heat on all
year just just for the record
according to celebs the app you got
channing tatum
channing tatum yes and then i got i
don't hate that
i got 97 pamela anderson
langler and i are back at the desk for
five minutes and i'm already
losing my mind okay not a bad way
the script is there okay this actually
is from a viewer
we call this mousy and it's mostly
intact
it still has its ears and stuff alex we
got to get you to a golden knights game
another one you haven't been to one yet
have you yeah we went together oh yeah
oh my gosh wow did you already forget
hector we are crying in here watching
you oh my gosh you almost dropped
someone
[Music]
hector oh my gosh
how many stories of mine have you had to
read i mean it's like at least
two a day there's you at new year's eve
uh
i think that was yeah silver night
anderson silver nights
oh remember super recycle event
that was from our first promo shoot at
uh makers and finders downtown there's
your boys
there's your boy tony where is in this
remember happy halloween
what honestly like what was that yeah
[Laughter]
yeah and also like all basketball
players in all seriousness
we love you alex and we're starting to
see you guys i am too
uh this i ain't so sadly but
you guys are the best and she hasn't
cried yet she's held onto the tears i'm
i'm proud of you
but here they come we love you we